we all have times in our lives where we
feel broken
a couple that on the brink of disaster
Brad versus Angie in the new 13-page
Vanity Fair expose the big Revelation
Brad wanted their French Chateau to be a
love letter to Angie and the kids
instead the bitter legal battle over the
winery has literally become a real-life
War of the Rose a play on the 1989 film
you will never get that house you
obviously want me dead I just want to
smash your face in still alive baby
quotes from the article in the beginning
Brad thought the world of that woman
outside the master bedroom he installed
30 small screens that flash pictures of
the kids he also built a petting zoo and
filled it with rabbits goats chickens
and peacocks for the family to enjoy
which is special to give it new life
Brad also transformed the recording
studio it was pretty dank in here you
know it still smelled like the 70s or
maybe the 80s to be fair in 2013 Brad
transferred 10 percent of his share to
Angelina to make her an equal partner
which was seemingly a show of his love
that's why when Angie reportedly sold
those shares for about 54 million
dollars it could be interpreted as a
slap in Brad's face Brad Pitt allegedly
put in 50 million dollars more than
Angelina Jolie into this business he put
in his time his energy Sweat Equity
there was always plans to revamp the
studio so this case is not only about
the money but it's really about the time
and the heart and the soul that he put
into this business that was supposed to
be for his kids
Vanity Fair also claims Angelina blasted
Brad in an email for this ad where the
actor who is now sober is asleep in a
lounge chair Angie reportedly writes the
image reminded me of painful times the
article sums it all up like this and
Jolie's telling it's a tale of alcohol
abuse and financial control for Pitt
it's one of Vengeance and retribution
now we have this undertone of a divorce
of allegations of abuse of child custody
that are not really what this case is
about but it's what's making it more
complicated and dramatic
[Music]